après le pas pour doudoune Macron
[Rires]
ce qui fait flipper c'est que c'est
extrêmement réaliste bien sûr
voilà c'est pas la fin du monde ça c'est
pas grave
si la photo est vraie problème comme ça
là avec des avec des avec des bagues et
des chaussures en plastique comme ça
et de la machine avec les animaux tu les
aimes pas les animaux j'adore les
animaux c'est quand même la conscience
tu les mets la photo comme ça tu auras
toujours une grande partie des gens qui
vous croire qu'elle est vraie comme les
gens croient que la terre est plateforme
une photo une autre photo
extrêmement compromettante par exemple
et ce serait les conséquences
dramatiques parce que vous croyez que
Macron il a ramassé des poubelles
sur l'évolution par exemple de ça de
l'intelligence artificielle ce qu'on a
vu sur les taxis c'est des algorithmes
c'est tout ça et ce cas c'est qu'on fait
confiance à tout ça alors on se pose des
questions mais ça va aller jusqu'où
Elaine musk a dit il y a quelques jours
je crois parce qu'il est pas dans le
business et que ce business lui échappe
c'est pour qu'il a fait là je vais faire
la peau l'intensité artificielle au
ralentir parce que ça prenait quand même
des proportions ça c'est quand même
super bien fait on ne sait pas il y a
des gens ils peuvent ne pas se poser de
questions et imagine on le voit avec une
femme oui oui
qu'on ne croit plus à l'image c'est fini
pour vous dire à tout le monde on
regarde Hollande mais c'était une
connerie non je je trouve que depuis la
nuit des temps et pour avoir fait ça un
peu en fac et sur le l'évolution de
l'industrialisation du monde à chaque
fois qu'on a dit il y a les robots il y
a ce qui arrive c'est la fin de 6 à la
fin de ça et au final tout ça c'est
plutôt bien passé donc à la force de à
force de jouer les cassandres comme
Béatrice rosette a toujours voir le mal
partout on avance plus je trouve après
peut-être que je me vaux il peut y avoir
des dérives sécuritaires autoritaires la
personne qui aura le contrôle de
l'intelligence artificielle aura
finalement le contrôle de l'humanité
parce que c'est c'est cette technologie
est beaucoup plus puissante que tous les
limitation de l'homme mais là vous
parlez d'un logiciel qui fait des photos
déjà un ça peut le mettre dans une
situation très compromettante avec un
ennemi avec une femme avec un homme avec
enfin ça peut créer des situations
extrêmement compliquées qui peuvent
mettre en danger la sécurité du plan
parce que police ça s'écrit pas comme ça
Paul tu vois il y a quand même des
pailles sécuritaires on a vu les robots
chiens qui ont été commandés on peut
leur mettre des armes dessus enfin les
dérives peuvent être dramatiques
et de Terminator il est trop au cinéma
vous en êtes au balbutie une fois que ce
sera sophistiqué je suis d'accord vous
aurez la guerre de la communication de
l'information vous aurez sur la guerre
en Ukraine des des fake news il
influencerons l'opinion mondiale et qui
créeront mais depuis
1939 la fake news c'est parti intégrante
de la manipulation des populations et
c'est pas c'est pas très nouveau alors
avant c'est avec du papier ou avec des
images
de propagande était totalement détournés
donc on aura plus les moyens de vérifier
quelqu'un pour ce que moi qu'il faut pas
s'armer non non
je pense que on peut très bien simuler
par exemple une attaque nucléaire et
auquel cas il y a une réplique immédiate
qui est automatique qui se fait ça c'est
wargame non non mais ça veut dire ça
veut dire tout simplement si on en
arrive là comment est-ce que le mec qui
appuie sur le bouton va dire est-ce que
c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise nouvelle
j'appuie où j'appuie pas et et si le
truc est bien fait comme la réplique est
automatique parce que si un jour
automatique du tout
il y a un protocole il y a un code il y
a deux clés à mettre non non pas du tout
concierge s'il faut répliquer
un missile nucléaire qui passe ça n'est
jamais Jean-Marie ça n'est jamais la
machine ce n'est jamais à la machine qui
déclenche le feu du fer c'est totalement
impossible c'est une légende urbaine
c'est les gens urbaine c'est pas vrai
heureusement on peut pas le prouver
puisque c'est si si on peut prouver et
en plus
arrivé et je vous rappelle que celui qui
crée la machine c'est l'homme sur Paris
par exemple détruit un tiers de la
population française c'est pas les
petits pétards d'Hiroshima quand on a
maintenant oui d'accord ce sont des
trucs et moi je te dis que que quand un
sous-marin par exemple est dans des eaux
il doit pas être s'il est aligné
simplement par un missile le sous-marin
est averti qu'il est aligné et il se
barre et ceux qui viennent étaient dans
un rushi dessus très sérieux je sais
mais la riposte la riposte est forcément
déclenchée par un être humain et pas et
par plusieurs personnes ah mais si il y
a le protocole est infaillible les
affaires commencez vous relativiser un
petit peu mais Elon Musk et Bill Gates
ils estiment quand même que la survie de
l'espèce humaine est menacée avec
l'intelligence artificielle sur
plusieurs années donc si ces hommes là
quand même qui sont quand même des des
vraies têtes pense que ça peut être
extrêmement dangereux la manière dont ça
va être utilisé je pense qu'il y a quand
même de quoi s'inquiéter moi je pense
que l'homme sera toujours plus au final
plus malin que le match je le souhaite
allez on se met le doute surtout
maintenant on croira plus à rien quand
on va le vendre
des multiplier de Daniel Moreau
regardez ça
il y a des mecs qui pensent que le papy
fait la trottinette
et là il est en doudoune
je vous dis que la désinformation et la
manipulation de l'opinion c'est des
dizaines et des dizaines
mais c'était même pire parce que à
l'époque il y avait moins de moyenne
comparaison aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui
est un petit peu averti peut elle peut
se renseigner
dans les années 40 c'était compliqué de
vérifier ce qu'on me disait excuse-moi
j'ai foi en l'être humain sauf que
l'intelligence artificielle ne concerne
pas seulement l'information il y a des
choses très concrètes il y a des robots
il y a il y a le million d'emplaire
excusez-moi dans le médical ça donne ça
rend des services
mais c'est toujours il y a le bon il y a
le bon moment il y a des pays quel
contrôle il y a des pays qui commencent
à interdire le fameux chat GPT là vous
voyez qui fait les choses à l'ouest
le nombre de conneries qui peut écrire
moi j'ai tapé mon nom par exemple
oui c'est ça ah c'est très drôle mais
oui n'importe quoi
parce que l'Italie prend conscience du
danger on devrait l'interdire c'est
c'est Bruno Le Maire le bruit
qui a dit que il pouvait faire des
discours politiques grâce à cette Chine
sur la Chine aujourd'hui et il a trouvé
le distributeur alors quand c'est des
données extrêmement économiques
documenté pourquoi pas mais quand vous
posez une question un peu un peu un peu
intelligente il vous sortez des
conneries mais ça menace 300 millions
d'euros dans le monde déjà pour
l'instant c'est ça qui me fait très très
peur
mais 53 c'est les hommes qui font les
robots
la clé de 33
je préfère avoir un bon robot qui a
gilbertez je vous dis franchement c'est
sûr ça c'est sûr